dans une vie de lycée typique, nous appartenons
à une nation mais je pensais avoir trouvé un
moyen d'obtenir la citoyenneté dans chaque nation
Greg comment était ton été été ce
mot signifiait même plus certains oh mon dieu ouais au
fil des ans
hé surtout traîné avec Earl il est plus
comme un collègue mais vous aimez les mêmes
choses larme de jus bon sang Votre Honneur je
veux vous parler de quelque chose
de triste ce qui s'est passé ouais elle était
Rachel eh bien vraiment Rachel a été
diagnostiquée avec nous sommes venus ici juste lui
donner un appel
je  j'ai besoin de ton stupide PT je suis en fait
ici ma mère me fait c'est en fait
pire ouais je sais juste laisse-moi passer du temps
avec toi pendant une journée
c'est que j'aimerais faire un salut puissant
j'allais pour un coup de poing je peux '  t premier
coup de poing d'ici te voir toi et Greg
êtes des collègues tu aimes les films tu
me fais un peu j'étais bon donc si
c'était une histoire romantique touchante
et du coup on s'embrasserait avec
le feu de mille soleils mais ça
n'est pas une histoire romantique touchante de toute
façon  lis la chose la plus importante que
tu puisses faire tu dois faire un film pour
Rachel donc tu aimes cette fille
tu es une bonne amie personne n'a fait
plus pour me faire sourire et personne n'a jamais
pu